oh it was terrifying I mean the moment I
realized that like we weren't gonna make
it to the hospital I was like screaming
yeah you wouldn't do a pretty school it
took my pain level to a whole nother
level for the beam fear ET spoke with
bachelor in paradise couple Jade and
Tanner via Skype the morning after they
accidentally welcomed baby number two in
their closet at what point did you
realize oh my god I'm gonna have to give
birth in this closet
we were watching the Bachelorette finale
with my mom and I wasn't sitting on the
couch I'm having labor pains for like
weeks so I didn't think anything of it
and then I felt this pop and it was my
water broke and so we called my midwife
and we were tiny my contractions they
were like six minutes apart and Emmys
labor took seven hours I knew it was
gonna be quick but not this big like
just just watch the time just like you
know don't have the baby in the car she
was like joking around so Tanner went
upstairs to shower I got in the bath
just to relax and we were gonna go that
we were gonna go to the hospital and all
of a sudden it was just like the labor
contractions sped up just got so intent
and sped up and I remember walking by my
a mirror and looking at my face and just
like the change of my body just like the
way it looks I was like this is serious
yeah so I yell a Tanner I'm in the
closet trying to get dressed so we can
go to the hospital
he's like helping me get into clothes he
puts me in his gym shirt at this stage
I'm just trying to get her dressed and
get her in the car so we can get there
you know but little did I know the head
was like Facebook down in the birth
canal already she couldn't walk well
he's like we need to get you down the
stairs and I was like this is not
contractions anymore like I need to push
I feel the he's coming this is like 30
40 minutes after the water broke the
same day fast immediate so Tanner's mom
came over to watch Emmy so she was there
and my mom was there we were all in the
closet I'm like hunched over clenching
this bench
Tanner's calling 9-1-1
and they got there in like six minutes I
got here so fast
and then within two minutes after they
got there he came out yeah when I was
back there before the English got there
I could see the whole head he was
crowning I was there by myself and our
mom but like a head of hair literally as
they walked in Jake gave the final push
BAM in the closet
you